Dimanche dernier, ma femme me demandait, en sortant de la prédication, qui avait pour titre favoritisme incompatible avec Dieu et son peuple,
elle me demandait quelle est la différence entre incompatibilité et incohérence.
N'est-ce pas la même chose ?
Eh bien, je profite de sa question pour y répondre en vous réfléchissant un peu la mémoire sur ce que nous avons déjà considéré
dans les cinq premiers versets du chapitre 2 au sujet de l'acception de personne.
L'acception de personne, que l'on peut aussi appeler favoritisme ou partialité, est un grave péché
qui consiste à mieux traiter une ou des personnes par rapport à d'autres sur la base de critères charnels
que l'on peut résumer par « selon ce qui frappe les yeux »,
plutôt que selon les critères de Dieu qui sont la justice, la vérité et l'amour,
que l'on peut résumer sous les principes de l'Évangile.
Et dans le contexte des Églises auxquelles Jacques adresse sa lettre,
ce favoritisme se manifestait par un traitement de faveur
qui était accordé à ceux qui avaient une apparence de richesse,
un habit magnifique, des anneaux d'or aux doigts
et une discrimination envers ceux qui avaient une apparence de pauvreté
qui était misérablement vêtue, nous dit le texte.
Mais il était intéressant de relever, en discutant avec quelques frères
après la prédication de dimanche dernier,
que l'acception de personne peut revêtir bien des formes.
Nous nous concentrons, c'est vrai, dans ce texte sur les riches et les pauvres,
mais l'exact même péché peut se manifester autrement
et plus subtilement dans nos vies et dans nos Églises, dans notre Église.
Nous pouvons favoriser certaines personnes selon leur aspect physique,
selon le niveau de leur diplôme, leur métier,
leur statut marital, le nombre d'enfants qu'ils ont,
leur façon de s'exprimer,
l'origine ethnique, la couleur de peau,
le caractère,
le niveau de connaissance théologique,
la maturité spirituelle,
la liste est potentiellement infinie.
Mais quelle que soit la forme qu'il prend,
la racine de ce péché d'acception de personne est toujours la même.
Et nous avons bien pris le temps d'en exposer toute l'horreur
en remontant jusqu'au premier péché que la création ait connu,
celui de Satan,
celui que Satan, la plus belle créature de Dieu,
a commis contre son créateur.
L'étendue de sa beauté,
de sa sagesse,
de sa perfection,
pour reprendre les mots du prophète Ézéchiel,
ont rempli Satan d'orgueil.
Orgueil qui étant la source de tout péché,
l'a amené à convoiter la place de Dieu
afin de détourner l'adoration des créatures de Dieu vers lui-même.
Et donc à la base de ce qui pousse quelqu'un à chercher
ou à honorer l'apparence de gloire,
quelle qu'en soit la forme,
à la racine, à la base de cela,
il y a l'orgueil
qui mène à convoiter pour soi-même
la gloire qui ne revient qu'à Dieu seul.
Mais la créature,
qu'elle soit un ange,
qu'elle soit un être humain,
qui tombe dans ce péché,
fait rapidement face à deux réalités immuables.
Personne ne peut prendre la place de Dieu
et celui qui essaye malgré tout
tombe au plus bas,
jusqu'en enfer.
Mais même du fond de l'enfer,
Satan,
ses démons
et chaque être humain
qui s'y trouve spirituellement dès sa naissance
continue de vouloir s'élever jusqu'au trône de Dieu.
Et cela donne lieu à une escalade mortelle
où chacun tente de s'élever le plus haut qu'il peut
au détriment des autres.
Tous les coups sont permis
afin d'atteindre ce qui semble être
un sommet de gloire aux yeux des hommes,
mais qui n'est qu'un mirage satanique
nous faisant croire que nous pouvons être égales de Dieu,
alors que nous ne sommes que des charognes spirituelles
qui veulent jouer au prince et au roi.
C'est cet esprit satanique
insufflé dans la chair d'Adam et Ève,
puis de chacun d'entre nous,
leurs descendants,
dès notre naissance,
qui pousse l'homme
à se considérer supérieur aux autres,
à convoiter
et à flatter celui qui est glorieux
aux yeux des hommes
et à mépriser celui
que personne ne considère.
Et si Jacques adresse cet avertissement très sérieux
à ses frères et sœurs,
c'est parce qu'il sait très bien
que si nous n'y prenons pas garde,
nous pouvons facilement retomber
dans ces vieux réflexes de notre chair,
même en tant que chrétien,
et même au sein de notre église locale.
Pourtant, comme nous l'avons vu dimanche dernier,
cette façon
de considérer notre prochain
selon les valeurs de ce monde
est absolument incompatible
avec le caractère de notre Dieu.
Contrairement à l'homme
qui se laisse facilement subjuguer
par ce qui frappe les yeux,
qui flatte le riche et le puissant,
qui se laisse corrompre par des présents,
qui cherche à être amis du riche,
à se faire bien voir de lui,
Dieu, lui, ne fait pas exception de personne
et il se présente
comme le défenseur de la veuve,
de l'orphelin, du pauvre et de l'étranger.
Le favoritisme est aussi incompatible
avec l'identité du peuple de Dieu.
Israël était le moindre des peuples
et parmi les membres de l'église,
il y avait peu de puissants et de nobles,
mais beaucoup de faibles,
de vils, de méprisés.
Et d'insignifiants.
Dieu se plaît à retirer le pauvre
de la poussière et du fumier l'indigent
pour les faire asseoir dans les lieux célestes
en Jésus-Christ.
Des rebelles graciés,
des esclaves anoublis,
des orphelins adoptés,
des étrangers accueillis.
Voici ce que nous sommes,
frères et sœurs.
Rechercher ou honorer la gloire personnelle
en faisant exception de personne,
d'autant plus en favorisant le riche
et en méprisant le pauvre,
est absolument incompatible
avec ce que nous sommes.
Des moins que rien aux yeux du monde,
des pauvres en esprit,
que Dieu a choisi dans son amour
et selon sa seule volonté,
pour en faire ses enfants,
pour en faire les héritiers
de son royaume éternel.
Et notre Dieu,
qui nous a ainsi fait grâce,
attend de nous que nous reflétions
son caractère,
ce qui rend le favoritisme
également incompatible
avec l'appel du peuple de Dieu.
La nation d'Israël,
qui était une nation théocratique,
c'est-à-dire que toutes les lois civiles
étaient dictées directement par Dieu,
au même titre que la loi morale
et les lois cérémonielles,
et bien cette nation devait,
à l'image de son Dieu,
rendre une justice impartiale,
une justice juste,
sans égard pour le pauvre
ni privilège pour le riche,
mais en écoutant aussi bien
le petit que le grand
et en jugeant chaque homme
selon la vérité et la justice.
C'est la définition de l'impartialité,
qui est évidemment l'exact opposé
de la partialité ou du favoritisme
ou de l'acception de personne.
Le peuple de Dieu
doit, conformément à ce que son Dieu
attend de lui,
ne pas faire exception de personne.
Et si cela était vrai
pour la nation d'Israël
dans l'Ancien Testament,
cela est vrai aussi pour l'Église
dans le Nouveau Testament.
Ces versets de Jacques
que nous étudions
le prouvent facilement,
ainsi que le témoignage
de la parole
et de l'histoire de l'Église.
Une des manifestations majeures
du fruit de l'esprit
dans la vie du chrétien,
c'est précisément le soin
des plus démunis,
que ce soit dans l'Église
ou dans la société.
Et donc,
pour en revenir à la question
de mon épouse,
voilà pourquoi
il y a une incompatibilité
entre le péché de favoritisme
et l'être de Dieu,
l'identité et l'appel
de son peuple.
Le fait que ce soit un péché
suffit déjà en soi
à le rendre incompatible
avec Dieu et son peuple.
Mais tout ce qui compose
ce péché en particulier,
comme nous l'avons vu
et que nous venons
de le rappeler,
le rend particulièrement
incompatible
avec Dieu et son peuple.
Tout comme l'eau et l'huile
ne peuvent se mélanger,
l'acception de personnes
et la foi chrétienne
ne peuvent coexister,
elles sont incompatibles
l'une avec l'autre.
Donc l'emphase
dans l'incompatibilité
est mise sur l'opposition
entre la nature
de ce péché d'un côté
et la nature de Dieu
et l'identité
de son peuple,
de l'autre.
Et nous en venons maintenant
à l'incohérence
entre le favoritisme
et le message
de l'Évangile.
L'incohérence est plus
un problème de logique interne.
Quelqu'un qui vous parle
et dont le propos
ne mène nulle part
ou qui enchaîne
des idées contradictoires
tient un discours incohérent.
Vous n'arrivez pas
à saisir ni son but
ni sa logique.
La contradiction
caractérise l'incohérence.
Que ce soit la contradiction
entre deux choses
que je dis,
je suis un homme,
je suis une femme,
entre deux choses
que je fais,
je sors avec ma copine
non chrétienne
le samedi soir
et je vais à l'église
le dimanche
ou entre ce que je dis
et ce que je fais.
Mon corps,
mon choix,
mais je tue
le corps d'un autre
en avortant
sans lui laisser le choix
à lui.
L'incohérence
est donc caractérisée
par le désordre interne
et la contradiction.
Et donc l'emphase
est mise ici
sur une attitude
qui n'a pas de sens,
qui n'a pas de logique.
Et nous allons voir
ce matin
dans les versets 6 à 7
que dire
que nous sommes
réconciliés avec Dieu,
sauvés par Dieu
et unis au Christ
tout en pratiquant
l'acception de personnes
encore plus en faveur
du riche
qui outrage le pauvre
et blasphème
le nom du Christ
et au détriment du pauvre
est en effet
totalement incohérent
avec les principes
de notre règle
de vie chrétienne
qui est l'Évangile.
Quels sont tout d'abord
ces principes
de l'Évangile ?
Finalement,
nous les avons exposés
dans les deux
dernières prédications.
Dieu est le créateur
de toutes choses.
Il est trois fois saint.
L'être humain
a suivi Satan
dans sa rébellion
contre son créateur
et a corrompu
sa chair par le péché.
Le péché pousse
chaque être humain
dès sa naissance
à constamment pécher
davantage
et le maintien éloigné
de Dieu
et maudit en enfer.
Et l'être humain
n'a ni la volonté
ni la force
en lui-même
d'y changer
quoi que ce soit.
Il ne peut se libérer
lui-même
et encore moins un autre
de cette corruption
du péché originel
et de sa juste
condamnation en enfer.
Même si nous voulions
sortir de l'enfer,
nous ne le pourrions pas.
Et même si nous voulions
entrer au paradis,
nous ne le pourrions
pas non plus.
Nous sommes justement
maudits
et condamnés par Dieu
à cause de nos péchés
dès notre naissance.
C'est pourquoi
Dieu le Fils
s'est incarné
dans la chair d'un homme
afin d'obéir
parfaitement
en tant qu'homme
à la loi de Dieu
à notre place
et d'offrir à Dieu
son sang humain
comme sacrifice
parfait à la croix.
C'est cette glorieuse
double transaction
par laquelle
Christ nous arrache
miséricordieusement
de l'enfer
par son sacrifice
et nous fait entrer
gracieusement au paradis
par sa justice.
Tout en nous
méritait l'enfer
et rien en nous
ne méritait le paradis
mais uniquement
parce que Dieu
a choisi
de nous accorder
le don de la foi
en son Fils Jésus-Christ.
Tout ce que le Fils
a accompli
est vrai pour nous.
Nous sommes
déjà morts,
déjà ressuscités,
déjà glorifiés,
déjà assis
dans les lieux célestes
avec notre glorieux
Sauveur Jésus-Christ.
Notre salut entier
par grâce
malgré nos démérites
et à la gloire
du Dieu trinitaire.
Voici
ce qu'est l'Évangile.
Eh bien,
l'attitude
des destinataires
de Jacques
est incohérente
avec ces principes
de l'Évangile
pour trois raisons
qui nous serviront
de plan.
Premièrement,
ils cherchent
à plaire aux riches
alors que l'Évangile
nous délivre
de la crainte
de l'homme.
Deuxièmement,
ils cherchent
le secours des riches
alors que Dieu seul
sauve.
Et troisièmement,
ils cherchent
à s'allier aux riches
alors que ces derniers
blasphèment
le nom de Christ.
Verset 6
« Et vous, chrétiens,
vous avilissez
le pauvre. »
Les mots de Jacques
sont forts.
Il nous rappelle
tous ces versets
de l'Ancien Testament
que nous avons cités
dimanche dernier
qui décrivent
le traitement
tout à fait injuste
et dégradant
que les riches,
les chefs,
les juges d'Israël
avaient fini
par infliger
aux pauvres
jusqu'à y trouver
même du plaisir.
Souvenez-vous,
Amos 2, verset 6,
ils ont vendu
le juste
pour de l'argent
et le pauvre
pour une paire
de souliers.
Ils aspirent
à voir la poussière
de la terre
sur la tête
des misérables
et ils violent
le droit
des malheureux.
Et cette injustice
sociale devient
encore plus grave
lorsqu'on sait
que c'est Dieu
lui-même
que l'on enfance
en la pratiquant.
Opprimer le pauvre,
c'est outrager Dieu.
Mais avoir pitié
de l'indigent,
c'est honorer Dieu.
Proverbe 14, 31.
Les chrétiens
auxquels Jacques
écrit avaient
pour la majorité
fui
la persécution
de Jérusalem.
Ils avaient
connu
la pauvreté,
soit ils étaient
déjà
à Jérusalem,
soit ils le sont
devenus ensuite
en fuyant
la ville
et en laissant
leur bien
derrière eux.
Ils avaient vu
et probablement
bénéficié
de la solidarité
au sein
de l'Église
de Jérusalem
que vous pouvez lire
dans le livre
des Actes.
Alors comment
est-il possible
que ces chrétiens
se retrouvent
malgré cet
arrière-plan
à outrager
leur Dieu
en avilissant
le pauvre,
à emprunter
le même chemin
que les Israélites
contemporains
des Haïts
qui finirent jugés
par la destruction
de Jérusalem
et par l'exil
loin de leur
pays promis
à cause
de ce même péché ?
Certains versets
des prophètes
de l'Ancien Testament
peuvent nous aider
à comprendre
comment un chrétien
peut en arriver
progressivement
à de tels
comportements
incohérents.
Rappelez-vous
que la source
de tout péché
est l'orgueil
et voici
ce qu'écrit
le prophète
Ézéchiel
au sujet
de la nation
juive
dans un chapitre
sur lequel
nous reviendrons
tout à l'heure.
Mais tu t'es confié
dans ta beauté
et tu t'es prostitué
à la faveur
de ton nom.
Tu as prodigué
tes prostitutions
à tous les passants
et tu t'es livré
à eux.
Ézéchiel 16
verset 15
Frères et sœurs
dès que nous prenons
pour acquis
une grâce de Dieu
quelle qu'elle soit
nous courons le risque
de nous confier
dans cette chose
de nous enorgueillir
dans l'illusion
de posséder cette chose
d'y avoir droit même
et nous risquons alors
de déshonorer
celui qui nous a
en réalité
accordé cette grâce
et qui nous la conserve
par sa providence.
Israël n'était pas
une nation
ils étaient
le moindre
de tous les peuples
mais Dieu les a choisis
pour manifester
la gloire
de sa puissance
de sa bonté
et de sa fidélité
aux yeux des nations.
Il en va de même
pour nous l'Église.
Notre seule raison d'être
c'est que nous avons
été choisis par Dieu
pour manifester
la gloire
de sa grâce
et de sa miséricorde
aux yeux des hommes.
Lorsque l'on prend
pour acquis quelque chose
on a aussi tendance
à l'oublier
et ces chrétiens
ont probablement
progressivement
oublié
d'où ils venaient
et quel Dieu
les avait retirés
de la boue
de leurs péchés
pour les asseoir
dans son temple céleste.
Comme nous l'avons vu
dimanche dernier
cet avilissement
du pauvre
est absolument incompatible
avec la nature
de Dieu
de son peuple
incohérent
avec les principes
de l'Évangile.
Nous sommes appelés
par Dieu
à être humbles
et amis des humbles
comme Christ
à prendre soin
des plus démunis
nous étions pauvres
et Dieu nous a
infiniment enrichis
en Jésus Christ.
Jésus Christ
qui s'est humilié
et qui a foulé
la poussière
de la terre
pour nous sauver.
Et donc il est évident
que mépriser
et avilir le pauvre
est totalement incohérent
avec le message
et les principes
de l'Évangile.
et vous
vous avilissez
le pauvre.
J'ai du mal
à croire
que ce mauvais traitement
envers les pauvres
était totalement
déconnecté
du favoritisme
envers les plus riches.
Comme nous l'avons
déjà dit
ces deux attitudes
vont très souvent
ensemble.
Elles sont liées
car elles ont
la même origine
satanique
qui consiste
à nous élever
en abaissant les autres.
Mais nous allons voir
qu'en plus
de cette origine
satanique commune
le mépris du pauvre
fait très probablement
partie de
toute une stratégie
dont le but
est de s'attirer
la faveur
des hommes puissants
même si cela
se fait au détriment
des principes
de l'Évangile.
Nous devons nous rappeler
le contexte
de ces chrétiens
pour comprendre
cette situation.
Ils ont fui
Jérusalem
à cause de la persécution.
Où qu'ils soient
ils sont susceptibles
d'être maltraités
par les juifs
par les romains
ou par les deux ?
Et de plus
comme nous l'avons vu
la majorité
de ces chrétiens
est pauvre.
N'est-il pas tentant
dans de telles circonstances
de s'attirer
les faveurs
de ceux
qui ont le pouvoir
et les moyens
de les aider
et de les protéger ?
Et si nous élargissons
la question
pour nous y inclure ?
Ne sommes-nous pas
souvent tentés
afin d'éviter
les épreuves
ou d'en sortir ?
De plaire aux hommes
et de s'allier
à eux
plutôt que de compter
sur Dieu
en lui restant fidèle ?
La première étape
de cette stratégie
consiste donc
à plaire aux hommes
et en l'occurrence
dans ces versets
à plaire aux hommes riches.
Dans ce contexte,
il se peut même
que ces chrétiens
avilissaient le pauvre
afin de montrer aux riches
qu'ils étaient comme eux,
qu'ils appartenaient
à leur groupe,
qu'ils avaient
la même vision
du monde qu'eux,
car c'était en effet
très commun
pour les riches
à cette époque
et dans cette société
de mépriser les pauvres.
Pour vous donner
une illustration,
ça ressemble
à cette scène
assez triste
que l'on retrouve
dans beaucoup de films
plutôt pour adolescents,
pour filles adolescentes,
où l'héroïne arrive
au lycée
avec les copines
qu'elle a depuis
la maternelle
et qui,
pour s'intégrer
au groupe de filles
plus âgées,
plus populaires,
renie ses amis,
se met à les mépriser,
à les critiquer,
à s'en moquer.
Elle cherche l'approbation
d'un nouveau groupe
de filles
qui, d'après elle,
contrairement
à ses amis du collège
un peu ringardes
dans ce nouvel environnement,
pourront l'aider
à mieux s'intégrer
et à devenir,
elle aussi,
populaire.
Et ceux d'entre eux
qui assistent
à notre série
du vendredi soir
sur la crainte
de l'homme
savent
quelle est la racine
d'une telle attitude.
La crainte de l'homme,
la crainte
du regard des autres,
d'être mal vu,
d'être rejeté,
d'être moqué,
d'être blessé.
Ce qui peut nous pousser
jusqu'à pécher
contre Dieu
et notre prochain,
même contre notre frère
en Christ,
pour plaire aux hommes,
c'est en réalité
notre crainte de l'homme
qui surpasse
notre crainte de Dieu.
Que ferais-je
si je ne suis pas bien vu
par les gens
de ma classe,
par mes collègues
de travail,
par mes coéquipiers
du sport,
les membres
de mon association ?
Comment m'en sortirais-je
si je reste seul,
exclu de tout groupe,
si tous me critiquent
et m'excluent ?
Je ne survivrais pas.
Mieux vaut trouver
un moyen
de me faire accepter,
quitte à me compromettre
moralement,
doctrinalement,
spirituellement.
Ce sont
de telles pensées
qui durent traverser
l'esprit
des chefs d'Israël
qui crurent
à l'enseignement
de Jésus.
Voyez comment
ces versets de Jean
sont clairs
sur la raison
de leur résistance
malgré leur nouvelle conviction.
Jean 12, 42.
Cependant,
même parmi les chefs,
plusieurs crurent à lui.
Mais à cause
des pharisiens,
ils n'en faisaient
pas l'aveu
dans la crainte
d'être exclus
de la synagogue,
car ils aimèrent
la gloire des hommes
plus que la gloire
de Dieu.
Toutes ces pensées
sont de savants
mensonges du diable
qui n'a de cesse
de nous faire croire
que nous ne pourrons
pas nous en sortir
sans désobéir à Dieu,
qu'en tout cas,
le chemin de Dieu
est toujours
le plus pénible
et le moins gratifiant.
Comment faire
pour ne pas tomber
dans son piège
et ne pas croire
à ses mensonges
et vaincre
ses pensées mauvaises ?
La réponse sera
la même
à chaque fois.
Nous devons
nous rappeler
les glorieuses vérités
de notre salut
en Jésus-Christ,
les prêcher
à notre âme
et conformer
nos vies
au principe
de l'Évangile.
Nous devons
tout d'abord
nous rappeler
que ce n'est pas
des hommes
que nous devrions
avoir peur,
mais de Dieu.
Voici ce que
Jésus enseigna
à ses amis,
à ses disciples
que nous sommes
nous aussi
réunis ce matin.
Je vous dis
à vous
qui êtes mes amis,
ne craignez pas
ceux qui tuent le corps
et qui après cela
ne peuvent
rien faire de plus.
Je vous montrerai
qui vous devez craindre.
Craignez celui
qui,
après avoir tué,
a le pouvoir
de jeter dans la gêne.
Oui,
je vous le dis,
c'est lui
que vous devez craindre.
Jésus-Christ
dit ça
à ses amis
qui le suivent,
qui croient en lui.
Dieu est le seul
juge
dont le jugement
est parfait
et qui a le pouvoir
d'envoyer notre âme
en enfer
ou au paradis.
Et c'est bien cela
qui devrait préoccuper
le plus l'homme pécheur
ainsi que le chrétien,
ce que Dieu pense de nous
et non ce que les hommes
pensent de nous.
Mais la bonne nouvelle
de l'Évangile,
c'est que par la vie
d'obéissance parfaite
qu'il a offerte
à Dieu
en sacrifice
d'expiation
sur la croix,
Jésus-Christ,
notre glorieux Sauveur,
a satisfait
la justice de Dieu
et l'a réconcilié
avec nous
pour toujours.
Romains 8, 29
Car ceux
qu'il a connus d'avance,
il les a aussi prédestinés
à être semblables
à l'image de son Fils.
Afin que son Fils
fût le premier-né
d'entre plusieurs frères
et ceux
qu'il a prédestinés,
il les a aussi appelés
et ceux
qu'il a appelés,
il les a aussi justifiés
et ceux
qu'il a justifiés,
il les a aussi glorifiés.
Que dirons-nous
donc à l'égard
de ces choses
si Dieu est pour nous,
qui sera contre nous ?
Si Dieu est parfaitement
et définitivement
apaisé envers nous,
plus que cela,
s'il est maintenant
notre Dieu,
notre Père,
notre défenseur,
si nous avons
Jésus-Christ lui-même
comme avocat
devant Satan
et les hommes,
si le Juge suprême
des âmes
nous déclare justes
et que le Roi des rois
combat pour nous,
quelle place reste-t-il
pour la crainte des hommes
dans notre cœur,
frères et sœurs ?
Voyez-vous
comme la compréhension
de l'Évangile
et l'assurance
de notre réconciliation
avec Dieu
en Jésus-Christ
est liée
à notre crainte
ou notre non-crainte
des hommes ?
Et voici
quelques versets
pour achever
de vous convaincre
que la crainte
des hommes
est charnelle,
vaine
et opposée
à la confiance
en Dieu.
La crainte des hommes
tend un piège
mais celui
qui se confie
en l'Éternel
est protégé.
C'est donc
avec assurance
que nous pouvons dire
le Seigneur est mon aide,
je ne craindrai rien
que peut me faire
un homme.
L'Éternel est pour moi,
je ne crains rien
que peuvent me faire
des hommes.
Donc,
craindre les hommes
plus que Dieu
et chercher
à leur plaire
pour obtenir
leur approbation
est une attitude
totalement incohérente
avec les principes
de l'Évangile
car en Jésus-Christ,
nous sommes déjà
parfaitement
et définitivement
approuvés par Dieu,
le juge des âmes.
Mais si malgré cela,
nous continuons
à craindre les hommes,
alors nous chercherons
à leur plaire
dans le but
d'obtenir
plus ou moins
directement
leur faveur
et leur protection.
Et nous voici
face à une seconde
incohérence
avec l'Évangile,
chercher le secours
des hommes
alors que Dieu
seul sauve.
Comme souvent,
nous devons nuancer.
Il n'est pas mauvais
en soi
de recevoir
en tant que chrétien
de l'aide
de personnes riches,
puissantes
ou influentes,
même non-chrétiennes.
Même si l'on se cantonne
à la période
de la réforme protestante,
par exemple,
nous avons
plusieurs situations
où les réformateurs
ont bénéficié
de soutien politique,
financier
ou matériel
de la part
d'hommes
riches
et puissants.
Martin Luther
a été protégé
par Frédéric III
de Saxe
après la diète
de Worms
où il fut déclaré
hors la loi
par Charles Quint.
Et c'est ce
Frédéric III
de Saxe
qui a organisé
l'enlèvement simulé
de Luther
pour le cacher
dans son château
de Wartburg.
Château
où Luther
a pu traduire
la Bible
en allemand
pour tout
le peuple allemand.
Et ce Frédéric III
de Saxe
financera aussi
indirectement
la diffusion
des écrits
réformés
dans toute
la Saxe.
Ce sont
des nobles
huguenots
qui sont
des protestants
français,
les huguenots,
comme la famille
de Coligny,
par exemple,
qui ont financé
l'Académie de Genève
fondée par Calvin
en 1559
où Calvin
formait des pasteurs
pour les envoyer
ensuite dans
toute l'Europe
et dans les colonies
du Nouveau Monde
comme au Brésil.
Et donc,
quelque part,
si nous avons
des Brésiliens
avec nous
aujourd'hui,
c'est grâce
aux riches
familles protestantes
françaises.
Non,
c'est grâce
à Dieu,
bien sûr.
Zwingli
fut soutenu
par les marchands
et les artisans
de Zurich
qui voyaient
dans la réforme
un moyen
de s'affranchir
de l'autorité
épiscopale
et surtout
des taxes.
Et Zwingli
ne se priva pas
de dénoncer
leur avarice
mais il dépendait
néanmoins d'eux
pour imposer
ces réformes.
Et un dernier exemple
avec John Knox
qui fut soutenu
par des nobles
protestants
comme le comte
Darguil
en Écosse
pour renverser
la régente
catholique
Marie de Guise
et établir
la réforme
en Écosse.
Et les nobles
ont financé
l'impression
de la confession
écossaise
et ont protégé
John Knox
contre les persécutions.
Et nous pourrions
citer
beaucoup d'autres
exemples
rien que dans
cette période
mais aussi dans
d'autres
de l'histoire
de l'Église.
Toutefois
pour nuancer
la nuance
et comme vous avez
pu le percevoir
dans certains
de ces exemples
nous verrons plus tard
que de telles
alliances
même si elles sont
légitimes
par principe
dans la pratique
à cause du péché
se révèlent souvent
être source
de tensions
théologiques
et surtout
de compromis
moraux
pour le chrétien.
Mais il n'en reste
pas moins légitime
d'être soutenus
et protégés
par les puissants
de ce monde
si Dieu
incline leur cœur
vers la cause
de l'Évangile
et que cela
n'implique pas
de compromis
théologiques
ou moraux
de notre part.
Ces hommes
riches et influents
peuvent être
de vrais croyants
qui utilisent
leurs ressources
pour l'avancement
du royaume
de Dieu sur Terre.
Plusieurs ministères
aux États-Unis
dont nous sommes proches
pour certains
sont très généreusement
soutenus
par des familles
chrétiennes
très fortunées.
Même des riches
non-croyants
peuvent être
des outils
de la providence
de Dieu
qui nous viennent
en aide
par des moyens
secondaires
dans le cadre
de sa grâce commune.
Ce qui est mauvais
cependant
c'est de chercher
le secours
ou le soutien
d'hommes riches
et influents
sans le chercher
auprès de Dieu
ou au détriment
de notre obéissance
à Dieu.
Et c'est clairement
ce que font ces chrétiens
auxquels Jacques écrit.
Parce qu'ils craignent
les hommes plus que Dieu
ils cherchent
à leur plaire
pour obtenir
peut-être leur soutien
et ce faisant
ils avilissent
le pauvre
et donc
outrage
celui qui l'a fait
c'est-à-dire Dieu
qui les a pourtant sauvés
au prix de la vie
de son fils unique.
Peut-être que ces chrétiens
prient pour leur situation
mais sans foi
avec un cœur double
comme le dit Jacques
au chapitre 1.
Peut-être implorent-ils
le secours de Dieu
avec leurs lèvres
mais dans leur cœur
ils en attendent plus
des hommes riches
qui pourraient
peut-être selon eux
les protéger
concrètement.
Mais à cela
s'ajoute une incohérence
plus grande encore
proche de la folie
je dirais.
non seulement
ces chrétiens ont l'air
de plus se confier
en l'homme
qu'en Dieu
mais de plus
ils cherchent
leur secours
auprès d'hommes
qui les oppriment
et les traînent
devant les tribunaux.
Comment en vient-on
à chercher le secours
auprès de ses ennemis
en nous laissant
progressivement aveuglés
par les mensonges
de notre chair ?
C'est Dieu
qui t'a mis
dans les problèmes.
Cela fait des mois
des années
que tu souffres
que tu pries
et toujours aucune réponse
de ton Dieu.
Peut-être qu'il ne t'aime
pas tant que ça
peut-être qu'il ne t'entend pas
ou qu'il ne peut rien changer
à ta situation.
Il serait peut-être temps
de chercher de l'aide ailleurs.
Peut-être que si tu as
la bonne approche
ces hommes puissants
pourraient t'aider
eux.
Le péché peut avoir
un puissant effet aveuglant
sur notre esprit
lorsque nous sommes
dans l'épreuve
et nous faire tomber
dans la mauvaise foi
et l'incohérence
la plus totale.
Malheureusement,
la nation d'Israël
est encore
un bon exemple
de cela.
Voici comment Israël
éprouvait dans le désert.
Écoutez bien,
on est venu
à idéaliser
son passé en Égypte
et à minimiser
son esclavage
alors qu'ils y étaient
en réalité
opprimés
et affamés.
Nombre 11,4
Le ramassis de gens
qui se trouvaient
au milieu d'Israël
fut saisi de
convoitises.
Et même les enfants
d'Israël
recommencèrent
à pleurer
et dire
« Qui nous donnera
de la viande
à manger ? »
Nous nous souvenons
des poissons
que nous mangeons
en Égypte
et qui ne nous coûtaient
rien.
Des concombres,
des melons,
des poireaux,
des oignons.
Maintenant,
notre âme est desséchée,
plus rien.
Nos yeux ne voient
que de la manne.
Le péché
les aveugle
tellement dans l'épreuve,
cette épreuve
qu'ils traversent
dans le désert,
qu'ils en viennent
à désirer retourner
en esclavage
en Égypte.
Ils dirent à Moïse
« N'y avait-il pas
des sépulcres en Égypte
sans qu'il fût besoin
de nous mener
mourir au désert ? »
Que nous as-tu fait
en nous faisant sortir
d'Égypte ?
N'est-ce pas là
ce que nous te disions
en Égypte ?
Laisse-nous servir
les Égyptiens
car nous aimons mieux
servir les Égyptiens
que de mourir
au désert.
Vous savez
ce qui caractérise
Satan
et ses enfants ?
L'aide qu'ils apportent
a toujours un prix
qui est souvent
très élevé.
Et en ce qui concerne
Adam et Ève,
il s'agissait ni plus
ni moins que de leur vie.
À ce sujet aussi,
nous pourrions citer
de très nombreux
prophètes
de l'Ancien Testament.
Mais en voici un
qui regroupe
plusieurs aspects
que nous venons d'aborder.
Osée 7-8
Ephraim se mêle
avec les peuples.
Ephraim est un gâteau
qui n'a pas été retourné.
Des étrangers
consument sa force
et ils ne s'en doutent pas.
La vieillesse
s'empare de lui
et ils ne s'en doutent pas.
L'orgueil d'Israël
témoigne contre lui.
Ils ne reviennent pas
à l'éternel leur Dieu.
Ils ne le cherchent pas.
Malgré tout cela,
Ephraim est comme
une colombe stupide.
Sans intelligence,
ils implorent l'Égypte.
Ils vont en Assyrie.
Aveuglement,
orgueil,
rébellion,
folie.
Implorer le secours
de l'Égypte.
L'Égypte où il fut réduit
en esclavage
pendant plus de 400 ans.
L'Égypte dont Dieu
humilia les faux dieux
par ses diplées miraculeuses
dont il fit périr l'armée
dans la mer rouge.
L'ennemi historique d'Israël,
la nation idolâtre
par excellence,
mais une des nations
les plus puissantes
de l'époque.
Implorer le secours
de l'Égypte
est probablement
l'exemple le plus parlant
de cet aveuglement spirituel
dans lequel le désespoir
peut nous faire tomber
si nous n'y prenons pas garde.
Et voyez par ces mots
de Dieu lui-même
à quel point
cette démarche
vient d'un cœur rebelle
et sourd
à la voix de Dieu
qui est déshonoré
et offensé
par une telle attitude.
Esaïe 31
Malheur,
dit l'Éternel
aux enfants rebelles
qui prennent
des résolutions
sans moi
et qui font des alliances
sans ma volonté
pour accumuler
péché sur péché
qui descendent en Égypte
sans me consulter
pour se réfugier
sous la protection
de Pharaon
et cherchent un abri
sous l'ombre de l'Égypte.
La protection de Pharaon
sera pour vous
une honte
et l'abri
sous l'ombre de l'Égypte
une ignomine.
Frères et sœurs,
lorsqu'il nous arrive
de tomber
dans la même tentation,
de chercher le secours
auprès d'hommes
qui, de plus,
ne nous veulent pas
du bien à la base,
nous devons retenir ceci.
C'est toujours
une stratégie décevante
qui nous mènera
assurément
à une situation
bien pire
qu'elle ne l'était
au départ.
Et sachez
qu'il en est
toujours ainsi
avec les promesses
et les stratégies
de Satan.
Elles paraissent
faciles à mettre
en place
et efficaces
au départ.
Mais plus le temps
passe,
plus la vérité
apparaît au grand jour
et mes amis,
soyez sûrs
qu'écouter Satan
à la place de Dieu,
chercher l'approbation
et le secours
des hommes
plutôt que de Dieu,
chercher à régler
nos problèmes
par nos efforts humains
sans compter sur Dieu
dans la prière,
tout cela vous mènera
assurément
à une situation
bien pire
et plus éprouvante
que celle de départ.
Écoutez
le prophète Jérémie
décrire les conséquences
d'une telle stratégie
mise en place
par la nation d'Israël.
Mais si vous n'obéissez
pas à la voix
de l'Éternel,
votre Dieu,
et si vous dites
« Nous ne resterons
pas dans ce pays,
nous en nous irons
au pays d'Égypte
et nous ne verrons
point la guerre
où nous n'entendrons
pas le son de la trompette
où nous ne manquons
pas de pain,
et c'est là
que nous habiterons. »
Alors écoutez
la parole de l'Éternel
reste de Judas.
Ainsi parle l'Éternel
désarmé le Dieu d'Israël.
« Si vous tournez
le visage
pour aller en Égypte,
si vous y allez
demeurer,
l'épée que vous redoutez
vous atteindra
là,
au pays d'Égypte.
La famine
que vous craignez
s'attachera à vous
là, en Égypte,
et vous y mourrez.
Tous ceux
qui détourneront
le visage
pour aller en Égypte
afin d'y demeurer
mourront par l'épée,
par la famine
ou par la peste,
et nul n'échappera,
ne fuira devant
les malheurs
que je ferai venir
sur eux. »
Car la réalité,
frères et sœurs,
c'est que
Satan
et l'homme
charnel
sont très forts
pour nous donner
une impression
de puissance,
pour nous faire croire
que leurs capacités
sont bien plus élevées
que ce qu'elles ne sont
en réalité.
mais à la fin,
ils se révèlent
incapables
de nous secourir.
Soit parce qu'ils
ne le peuvent pas,
soit parce qu'ils
ne le veulent plus,
n'en ont jamais eu
l'intention.
Contrairement à notre Dieu,
Satan et l'homme
charnel ne sont pas
des soutiens
dignes de confiance.
Ephraïm voit son mal
et Judas s'éplait.
Ephraïm se rend
en Assyrie
et s'adresse
au roi Jareb.
« Mais ce roi
ne pourra ni vous guérir
ni porter remède
à vos plaies.
Ne vous confiez pas
dans les grands,
dans les fils de l'homme
qui ne peuvent sauver.
Leur souffle s'en va,
ils retournent à la terre
et ce jour-là,
leurs desseins périssent.
Ce n'est pas une grande armée
qui sauve le roi.
Ce n'est pas une grande force
qui dérive le héros.
Le cheval est impuissant
pour assurer
et le salut
et toute sa vigueur
ne donne pas
la délivrance.
Voici,
l'œil de l'Éternel
et sur ceux
qui le craignent,
sur ceux
qui espèrent
en sa bonté
afin d'arracher
leur âme à la mort
et de les faire vivre
au milieu
de la famine.
Mieux vaut chercher
un refuge en l'Éternel
que de se confier
à l'homme.
Mieux vaut chercher
un refuge en l'Éternel
que de se confier
au grand.
Il est normal
que nous cherchions
à nous extraire
d'une situation difficile,
injuste
et éprouvante.
Nous étions frappés
avec mon épouse
dans notre lecture familiale
du livre des actes
du nombre de fois
où l'apôtre Paul
a fait valoir
ses droits
de citoyen romain
pour échapper
à la persécution
des Juifs.
Il n'est ni interdit
ni offensant
envers Dieu
de tout faire
pour échapper
même à la persécution,
d'utiliser des moyens
humains
de bénéficier
de la grâce commune
pour cela.
Mais remarquez
que lorsque la volonté
de Dieu devient claire
pour l'apôtre Paul,
il ne résiste plus
et il engage alors
toutes ses forces
dans l'évangélisation
des personnes
qui l'entourent
dans ce nouveau contexte
de vie
voulu par Dieu,
ses gardiens,
les prisonniers,
les gouverneurs
qu'il croise.
C'est le même état d'esprit
que le roi David
qui a prié,
qui a jeûné
de toutes ses forces
pour supplier Dieu
d'épargner son fils.
Mais lorsque ce dernier
finit par mourir,
du jour au lendemain,
David reprit
une vie normale.
Il avait accepté
la décision de Dieu
et à aucun moment
dans son deuil
ou dans ses supplications,
il n'a déshonoré Dieu.
Il n'a pas rendu
un mauvais témoignage
en cherchant de l'aide
par des moyens iniques
auprès des hommes
car aucune épreuve,
aussi dure soit-elle,
ne peut justifier
de faire cela.
Chercher le secours
auprès des hommes
sans compter sur Dieu
est donc incohérent
avec les principes
de l'Évangile
car seul Dieu
est le sauveur
tout-puissant,
fiable
et fidèle.
C'est déjà une mauvaise chose
de craindre les hommes
plus que Dieu
et donc de chercher
à leur plaire,
presque toujours
d'une manière
qui déplaira à Dieu
d'ailleurs,
pour obtenir leur soutien
sans compter sur Dieu.
Mais c'est encore pire
de chercher de manière,
de chercher à plaire
de manière inique
à des hommes iniques
en outrageant avec eux
le beau nom
que nous portons,
celui du Christ.
Car c'est bien
ce que font
les chrétiens
de ces églises
selon Jacques.
Ils honorent
ceux qui outragent
le beau nom
qu'ils portent.
Ces chrétiens
se rendent-ils compte
qu'en mimant ainsi
l'attitude des riches
envers les pauvres,
en faisant cette
exception de personnes,
ils outragent
aux côtés des riches
le beau nom
de leur sauveur,
Jésus-Christ.
C'est une chose
de chercher à plaire
aux hommes
parce qu'on craint
leur regard.
C'est une chose
d'attendre plus
de secours
de la part des hommes
que de la part de Dieu.
C'est une chose
de chercher à amadouer
nos ennemis
pour en faire des alliés.
Mais c'est encore pire
de tout faire
pour être amis
avec ceux
qui blasphèment
le nom de Christ
dans l'espoir
d'obtenir leur aide.
C'est l'aveuglement
spirituel
qui continue
et qui atteint
son paroxysme.
Et que Satan
est fier
lorsqu'il voit
des chrétiens
si désespérés
et en même temps
si incrédules
tourner le dos
à leur Dieu,
à leur frère
Jésus-Christ
pour se tourner
vers des hommes
blasphémateurs
pour implorer
leur secours.
Et combien de fois
cela peut nous
arriver encore
à nous chrétiens
subtilement
en riant
à la blague
inappropriée
d'un collègue
en ne disant rien
ou même
en approuvant
l'opinion
non-biblique
d'un ami
en nous laissant
embarquer
dans une activité
inappropriée
par un élève
de notre classe
en obéissant
à une instruction
immorale
de notre patron.
Dans tous
ces exemples
ce qui dicte
notre conduite
c'est notre crainte
du regard
de l'homme
qui mène au désir
de lui plaire
puis au compromis
moral
et finalement
au péché.
Et cela peut nous mener
comme les dessinateurs
de Jacques
à faire des choses
totalement incompatibles
avec notre nouvelle nature
et incohérentes
avec les principes
de l'évangile.
Alors qu'ils sont
eux-mêmes pauvres
et appelés à prendre
soin des pauvres
ces chrétiens
se placent
aux côtés des riches
les flattent
miment leur comportement
envers les pauvres
alors que ce sont
ces mêmes riches
qui les oppriment
les traînent
devant les tribunaux
et outrage
le bon nom
qu'ils portent.
Quelle incohérence !
Faisons un nouveau appel
à la voix des prophètes
de l'Ancien Testament
qui nous montrent
que la nation d'Israël
avait fini par se confier
dans sa beauté
orgueil
à favoriser le riche
et retirer son droit
aux pauvres
dans ses jugements
favoritisme
et à établir
des alliances
impies
avec des nations
riches, puissantes
et bien entendu
idolâtres
au lieu de se repentir
et d'implorer
le secours
de l'Éternel
leur Dieu.
Malheur à ceux
qui descendent en Égypte
pour avoir du secours
qui s'appuient
sur des chevaux
et se fient
à la multitude
des chars
et à la force
des cavaliers
mais qui ne regardent
pas vers le Saint d'Israël
et ne cherchent pas
l'Éternel.
Lui aussi cependant
il est sage,
il fait venir le malheur
et ne retire point
ses paroles,
il s'élève
contre la maison
des méchants
et contre le secours
de ceux
qui commettent
l'iniquité.
Et voyez comme le fait
de conclure
de telles alliances
avec des idolâtres
qui commettent
l'iniquité
est toujours lié
au fait de se détourner
de Dieu
et de sa volonté.
Malheur,
dit l'Éternel
aux enfants rebelles
qui prennent
des résolutions
sans moi
et qui font des alliances
sans ma volonté
pour accumuler
péché sur péché
qui descendent
en Égypte
sans me consulter
pour se réfugier
sous la protection
de Pharaon
et chercher un abri
sous l'ombre
de l'Égypte.
Et enfin,
de manière très claire,
Proverbe 25-19,
comme une dent cassée
et un pied
qui chancelle.
Ainsi est la confiance
en un perfide
au jour
de la détresse.
Frères et sœurs,
nous devons comprendre
que tout cela
est une affaire
très sérieuse
de fidélité
à notre roi Jésus-Christ.
À qui avons-nous
réellement fait
allégeance ?
À Satan
ou à Christ ?
Quelle voix
écoutons-nous ?
Quels conseils
prenons-nous
en compte au quotidien ?
Ceux de Dieu
ou ceux du diable ?
Ceux de la chair
ou ceux de l'esprit ?
Ceux des hommes iniques
ou ceux des hommes droits ?
Voici comment Paul
fait le lien
entre notre désir
de plaire à Dieu
et notre fidélité
à Christ.
Et maintenant,
est-ce la faveur
des hommes
que je désire
ou celle de Dieu ?
Est-ce que je cherche
à plaire aux hommes ?
Si je plaisais
encore aux hommes,
je ne serais pas
serviteur de Christ.
Chercher à plaire aux hommes
et servir Jésus-Christ
est totalement incompatible
et incohérent
de notre part.
Tout comme le fait
de plaire aux hommes
et prêcher l'Évangile.
Selon que Dieu
nous a jugés dignes
de nous confier l'Évangile.
Ainsi,
nous parlons
non comme pour plaire
à des hommes
mais pour plaire à Dieu
qui sonde nos cœurs.
Et enfin,
les apôtres affirment
de manière claire
et simple,
Pierre et les apôtres
répondirent,
il faut obéir à Dieu
plutôt qu'aux hommes.
Nous ne pouvons pas
servir Christ
et chercher
à plaire aux hommes.
Nous ne pouvons pas
prêcher l'Évangile
et plaire aux hommes.
Nous ne pouvons pas
obéir à l'esprit
de ce monde
et à Dieu.
Nous devons choisir
notre allégeance
et y rester fidèles.
Je mentionnais tout à l'heure
le soutien
que certains réformateurs
ont pu recevoir
d'hommes riches
et puissants.
Voici une anecdote
très triste
qui nous montre
que même
les grands théologiens
de l'histoire
restent des hommes
faillibles,
sujets aux erreurs
de jugement,
des hommes dont la chair
est susceptible
de tomber
dans l'acception
de personnes,
de créer des alliances
impies
par stratégie humaine.
Philippe de Hesse,
prince clé
de la ligue
de Smalclad,
c'était une alliance
des princes protestants
contre l'empereur
catholique Charles Quint.
Ce prince,
Philippe de Hesse,
demande en 1539
l'autorisation
aux réformateurs
dont Luther
d'épouser
une seconde femme,
Marguerite von Dersal,
alors qu'il était
déjà marié.
Face à ce dilemme,
Luther et ses acolytes
hésitent longuement.
Refuser risquerait
de perdre
le soutien politique
de Philippe,
un pilier de la réforme.
Mais accepter
reviendrait
à cautionner
un acte
moralement condamnable
et scandaleux.
Après des débats
âpres,
ils cèdent,
autorisant secrètement
ce mariage bigame
malgré leur réticence
théologique
et leur crainte
des conséquences
pour la crédibilité
de leur mouvement
de réforme.
Un an plus tard,
en 1540,
le scandale
éclate au grand jour.
menaçant de discréditer
la réforme
et d'affaiblir
cette ligue
de Smalcalde.
Philippe,
sous la pression
des lois impériales
qui punissaient
la bigamie de mort,
se tourne vers
Charles Quint
pour négocier
son salut.
Et un an plus tard,
en juin 1541,
il trahit la ligue
en échange
du pardon
de Charles Quint,
portant un coup dur
à la cohésion
protestante.
Ce compromis moral
des réformateurs,
dicté par la peur
de perdre un allié puissant,
s'est retourné contre eux.
Leur réputation
en sort gravement entachée
et l'unité des protestants
s'en trouve fragilisée,
illustrant le lourd tribut payé
quand les impératifs politiques
l'emportent
sur les principes bibliques.
crainte des hommes,
recherche de soutien
auprès des hommes,
alliance avec des hommes impies,
compromis doctrinal et moral.
Résultat ?
Une trahison,
un dieu déshonoré,
un mouvement discrédité,
une situation pire
qu'elle ne l'était au départ.
Ces réformateurs
ont regardé
à ce moment-là
à ce qui frappe les yeux,
le risque de perdre
un soutien humain important
et ils ont négligé le cœur,
le péché
qui s'apprêtait à justifier.
Et Dieu a exposé
leur grave erreur
au grand jour.
Frères et sœurs,
ne tombons pas
dans les pièges de Satan
qui nous présentera
toujours un plan B
en apparence
meilleur que le plan A
de Dieu.
Le résultat sera toujours
décevant
et très souvent
catastrophique.
Voici les mots
de l'apôtre Paul
dans sa deuxième lettre
aux Corinthiens.
Ne vous mettez pas
avec les infidèles
sous un joug étranger.
Car quel rapport
y a-t-il entre la justice
et l'iniquité ?
Ou qu'y a-t-il de commun
entre la lumière
et les ténèbres ?
Quel accord y a-t-il
entre Christ et Bélial ?
Ou quelle part
a le fidèle
avec l'infidèle ?
Quel rapport y a-t-il
entre le temple de Dieu
et les idoles ?
Car nous sommes
le temple du Dieu vivant.
Comme Dieu l'a dit,
j'habiterai et je marcherai
au milieu d'eux.
Je serai leur Dieu
et ils seront mon peuple.
C'est pourquoi
sortez du milieu d'eux
et séparez-vous,
dit le Seigneur.
Ne touchez pas
à ce qui est impur
et je vous accueillerai.
Je serai pour vous
un père
et vous serez pour moi
des fils
et des filles,
dit le Seigneur
tout-puissant.
Lorsque Dieu le Père
fait de nous
ses enfants,
en transformant notre cœur
par son Esprit Saint,
nous plions le genou
devant la croix du Fils.
Nous passons
du royaume des ténèbres
au royaume
de son admirable lumière,
de la paternité
du diable
à celle de Dieu,
de l'esclavage
du péché
à la liberté
de la sainteté,
du règne
du prince de ce monde
au règne glorieux
et éternel du Christ roi.
Ce Christ,
notre héros,
a gagné notre cœur,
frères et sœurs,
comme nous l'avons entendu
ce matin
à l'introduction du culte.
Il a fait alliance
avec nous
comme un époux
avec son épouse
et nous lui avons juré
soumission,
honneur
et fidélité
pour l'éternité.
Ô combien nous attrissons
notre cher Sauveur
lorsque nous nous assayons
sur le banc
des blasphémateurs
de son glorieux nom
qui nous a gracieusement donné.
Lorsque nous cherchons
l'approbation,
l'amitié
et le secours
des blasphémateurs
du Christ,
nous ne commettons
rien de moins
qu'un adultère spirituel.
On reconnaît un homme
à ceux dont il s'entoure,
dit le proverbe.
Qui trouve-t-on
parmi vos amis ?
Avec qui passez-vous
le plus de temps ?
Avec qui désirez-vous,
appréciez-vous
le plus passé de temps ?
Dieu nous a créés
pour influencer
et pour être influencé.
Nous avons malheureusement
eu des cas de discipline
dans notre Assemblée
pour des personnes
qui ont progressivement
glissé dans le péché
et une des causes majeures
de cette chute progressive
fut le temps conséquent
que ces membres
passaient avec des non-chrétiens
plutôt que d'être proactifs
dans la communion fraternelle.
De qui cherchons-nous
l'amitié ?
Qui sont les personnes
qui nous influencent le plus ?
Quel est l'impact
des relations
que nous entretenons
dans nos vies ?
Nous devons être intentionnels
dans les relations
que nous entretenons
en prenant
tout cela en compte.
Tu es très influençable
m'a plusieurs fois
dit mon père
lorsque j'étais enfant.
Et je n'ai jamais
oublié cette phrase
elle a sonné
comme une alarme
à plusieurs reprises
dans ma vie.
Il est vrai
que j'étais à l'époque
attiré par les élèves
turbulents, provocateurs
c'est avec eux
que je voulais traîner
je voulais qu'ils me voient bien
qu'ils deviennent
mes amis.
Dès cet âge
j'étais guidé
par des valeurs
et des principes
charnels
et c'est probablement
le cas aussi
pour les destinataires
de Jacques.
Ils étaient attirés
par l'apparence
de richesse
à cause de la convoitise
de leur cœur.
Ils voulaient être
amis des riches
et étaient prêts
dans la pratique
en tout cas
à renier leur allégeance
à Christ
pour y parvenir.
Ne fréquente pas
l'homme colère
ne va pas
avec l'homme violent
de peur
que tu ne t'habitues
à ses sentiers
et qu'il ne devienne
un piège
pour ton âme.
Proverbe 22-24
Gardons-nous
de l'adultère spirituelle
frères et sœurs.
Notre allégeance
est à Christ seul.
Cherchez à nous allier
à ceux qui blasphèment
le nom de Christ
en parole
ou en acte
est une folie
totalement incohérente
avec les principes
de l'Évangile
car nous sommes
l'Église
l'épouse
du Christ.
Hier je vous demandais
de lire
Ézéchiel 16
un chapitre
bouleversant
et nous ne pourrons
pas le lire
en entier
maintenant
mais je voulais
m'arrêter
sur quelques versets
qui sont terribles
et je voudrais
que nous puissions
les lire
comme un avertissement
très sérieux
envers le risque
d'adultère spirituelle
que nous pouvons
commettre
si nous n'y prenons
pas garde.
Ces versets
nous enseignent
que lorsque
nous nous associons
avec des hommes
impies
écoutez bien
nous sommes
comme une femme
adultère
qui paierait
des hommes
pour pouvoir
se prostituer
avec eux.
Ézéchiel 16
30 à 34
Quelle faiblesse
de cœur
tu as eue
dit le Seigneur
l'Éternel
en faisant
toutes ces choses
qui sont l'œuvre
d'une maîtresse
prostituée.
Lorsque tu bâtissais
tes maisons
de prostitution
à l'entrée
de chaque chemin
lorsque tu faisais
tes hauts lieux
dans toutes les places
tu n'as pas même
été comme la prostituée
qui réclame un salaire
tu as été
la femme adultère
qui reçoit
des étrangers
au lieu de son mari
à toutes les prostituées
on paie un salaire
mais toi
tu as fait des dons
à tous tes amants
tu les as gagnés
par des présents
afin de les attirer
à toi
de toutes parts
dans tes prostitutions
tu as été le contraire
des autres prostituées
parce qu'on ne te cherchait pas
et en donnant un salaire
au lieu d'en recevoir un
tu as été le contraire
des autres
chercher à s'allier
d'une quelconque manière
à des hommes
qui blasphèment
le nom du Christ
de leur bouche
ou de leur main
est une grave offense
faite à Dieu
une incohérence totale
avec l'évangile
qui proclame
notre délivrance
de l'esclavage du péché
notre allégeance
au Christ roi
et notre union maritale
avec Dieu le Fils
mes frères et soeurs
le chapitre 16
d'Ézéchiel
ne serait pas aussi bouleversant
s'il se terminait
sur cette note désastreuse
il est vrai
que dans ces sept premiers versets
nous avons beaucoup exploré
la face sombre
de notre être
la profondeur
des racines du péché
dans nos cœurs
l'étendue
de la corruption
de notre chair
dès notre naissance
nous sommes des enfants
de Satan
qui désirons faire
sa volonté
comme l'a dit le Christ
et il n'y a que le miracle
de la nouvelle naissance
accomplie par Dieu
dans nos vies
qui peut changer cela
il n'y a que la fidélité
de Dieu
qui peut vaincre
notre rébellion
et c'est sur cette glorieuse
vérité que se termine
ce chapitre 16
d'Ézéchiel
après avoir exposé
toute l'horreur
de l'adultère spirituelle
dont Israël
s'est rendu coupable
Ézéchiel 16
60 à 63
Dieu dit
mais je me souviendrai
de mon alliance
avec toi
au temps de ta jeunesse
et j'établirai avec toi
une alliance éternelle
tu te souviendras
de ta conduite
et tu en auras honte
quand tu recevras
tes soeurs
les grandes et les petites
je te les donnerai
pour filles
mais non en vertu
de ton alliance
j'établirai mon alliance
avec toi
et tu sauras
que je suis l'éternel
afin que tu te souviennes
du passé
et que tu rougisses
afin que tu n'ouvres
plus la bouche
et que tu sois confuse
quand je te pardonnerai
tout ce que tu as fait
dit le Seigneur
l'éternel
Amen
Quelle grâce
et miséricorde
que celle de notre Dieu
Quelle merveilleuse nouvelle
que l'Évangile
cette déclaration
de paix divine
qui nous assure
que tous nos péchés
même nos convoitises
les plus sombres
même notre acception
de personnes
la plus blessantes
même notre crainte
des hommes
la plus grande
notre désir
de leur plaire
le plus profond
nos alliances
les plus iniques
nos incohérences
les plus folles
notre infidélité
la plus ingrate
et notre adultère spirituelle
le plus abominable
tous ces péchés
qui sont les nôtres
sont aujourd'hui
entièrement recouverts
du manteau
de justice du Christ
et Dieu
le juste juge
nous considère
et nous déclare
blancs comme neige
plus purs
que le diamant
sans impureté
parfaitement
et éternellement
innocent
alors frères et sœurs
si le Saint-Esprit
a révélé dans vos cœurs
certaines de ces tendances
que nous avons exposées
ces trois derniers dimanches
ne cherchez pas
à vous cacher de Dieu
n'oubliez pas
Christ met en lumière
toute l'étendue
de notre misère spirituelle
mais dans le but
de nous mener à genoux
et repentant
au pied de sa croix
où ses mains percées
nous relèvent
pour nous emmener
avec lui
au paradis
il n'est jamais trop tard
pour apprendre
à nous voir
les uns les autres
tels que Christ nous voit
et tels qu'il nous demande
de nous voir
nous et les autres
que lorsque nous nous rassemblons
en tant que son épouse
l'Église
nous puissions refléter
dès aujourd'hui
aux yeux des hommes
les valeurs
et les principes
de son royaume
qui n'est pas de ce monde
et je vous invite
à vous lever
pour que nous lisions
ses valeurs
les valeurs du royaume
auquel nous appartenons
et qui sont le remède
à toute exception
de personne
Matthieu 5
verset 13
pardon
3 à 12
heureux les pauvres en esprit
car le royaume des cieux
est à eux
heureux les affligés
car ils seront consolés
heureux les débonnaires
car ils hériteront la terre
heureux ceux qui ont faim
et soif de la justice
car ils seront rassasiés
heureux les miséricordieux
car ils obtiendront
miséricorde
heureux ceux qui ont le cœur pur
car ils verront Dieu
heureux ceux qui procurent
la paix
car ils seront appelés
fils de Dieu
heureux ceux qui sont persécutés
pour la justice
car le royaume des cieux
est à eux
heureux serez-vous
lorsqu'on vous outragera
qu'on vous persécutera
et qu'on dira faussement de vous
toutes sortes de mal
à cause de moi
réjouissez-vous
et soyez dans l'allégresse
parce que votre récompense
sera grande dans les cieux
car c'est ainsi
qu'on a persécuté
les prophètes
qui ont été avant vous
Amen